هناك ميزه كبيره جدا لهذه المنطقه
تجاره الصناعي
مركز هذه المنطقه مهمه جدا فيما يتعلق
الناحيه الزراعيه من ناحيه التجاريه في
نفس الوقت
لانها كانت مركزا مهما جدا في كل هذه
المجالات
كانه
من اهم المناطق التي تستطيع ان تلم شملها
وبشكل سريع
وتم تتويج الدعوه التي واجهها فخامه
الرئيس في الامم المتحده من قبل صديق
قبل سنه
امير دوله قطر سينتمم له الشيخ تميم جمهور
وفخامه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بزمده
في هذا اللقاء وتم تحقيق بالفعل ووضع
اللمسات الاولى لهذا المشروع تركيا
وتم تسجيل الخطوه الاولى من اجل عوده
السوريين اللي عايشين في تركيا الى هذه
المناطق الامنه سينكتر دشنا
وتم تقديم توجيهات من امير دوله قطر لوزير
خارجيه قطر وفخامه الرئيس رجب تايبردو عن
قدم توجيهات هي شخصيا
ليه
وقمنا بتحديد في منطقه درع الفرات ونبع
السلام
ساحات 9000 او تسعه ساحات او مناطق ملائمه
لهذه المشاريع